what you're looking at here are
manifolds specifically you're looking at
2d manifolds embedded in a 3d space so
naturally these are some kind of bodies
that have a surface and one of the
things you might want to do with a
manifold like this is to define a
convolutional neural network to work on
this surface so usually we have
convolutional neural network working on
flat surfaces such as images but what if
you could actually work on a manifold
like this an easy example is a sphere
you might want to work on a sphere why
is that useful maybe you want to predict
the climate and then you actually want
to work on the Earth's surface which is
approximated by a sphere so today we'll
look at the following paper
equivalent convolutional networks and
the icosahedral CNN by taco Kohan
Maurice Wyler Burke aye chief young
kitchen no glue and Mac swelling so as I
already said this paper tries to define
convolutional neural networks on any
kind of manifold so what's the problem
inherently when you're doing this can't
you just you know place a filter
move it around like you do in a regular
CNN that's exactly the problem actually
so if you have a picture and let me draw
a picture of a cat right cat here here
here here
hi I all right cat smiling this is a
terrible cat what you do is you have
your filter right and that's a little
patch in the image you just kind of move
this filter move it around
move it around and at each point you
convolve the filter if this is larger
you convolve each of the elements of the
filter here maybe even nine elements so
each of these elements here is convolve
dwith the underlying image at
and you aggregate all of them into a
single point usually by adding them up
and there you from this image you
produce a new image that is a different
thing so if this kernel here for example
is a specific kernel that detects lines
you might end up with or that detects
specifically up-down lines you might end
up with just the lines that go up and
down in this image so the eyes here here
right so this might be the result of
this convolution of course in CNN these
convolutional kernels then are learned
as parameters so it seems pretty easy
right you just simply take a kernel and
kind of shift it around each at each
point you you convolve the underlying
image and that's it well it's not so
easy if you work on a manifold and why
is that it's illustrated here on a
sphere so if you have a sphere and you
place a kernel it really matters which
direction you place the kernel of course
I mean it does on an image but bear with
me so here you place a kernel in the
direction of this arrow right you place
the kernel maybe like this here you
place your little kernel on it and you
say up basically up is here right and
then you move that kernel around and
ultimately you want to move it all the
way to the other side of the sphere so
back here you want to move it over there
you want to move it all around the
sphere right now what happens if you
move it this way right you convolve here
you move it this way you convolve here
you see already by the red arrows where
is up up is where the red arrow is point
all right if you move it along here the
red arrows will always point up up up up
up okay so you arrive back here with
your kernel I'm gonna draw this try to
draw this dashed with the up in the
kernel being this direction because
you've moved it around like so
but if you for some reason choose to
move your colonel in another direction
namely in this direction up here then as
you can see if you place it here and
then you place it here place it here you
place it back here and ultimately here
where is up if you just keep track of
where up is in your Colonel it's always
going to be to the front of the sphere
so on one hand you have up being to the
back here and on the other hand you have
one up being to the front here so this
doesn't match so it actually depends on
which path you take from this original
point to any other point it depends
which path you take well your colonel is
going to end up there and that's of
course very unfortunate because we're
not used to this on this on this 2d
thing because if I you know move it down
first and then up here over here sorry
where is up in my so if up is here if
it's down here up is here and over here
up is here and if I kinda move it
straight over here and then down and
then here and then here you see up is
always the same direction there is no no
problem in a flat surface that's that's
why we can simply define it as we do but
in in on a sphere or any kind of
manifold it's called parallel transport
is path dependent in technical terms the
way you transport it thing from one
place to another really depends on the
path you take so this paper is trying to
address this problem and define a
convolution on any manifold so how is
this done first of all to define a
convolution on a curved surface what
they do is they say okay we have a
convolutional filter and the
convolutional filter is actually some
sort of a flat object and it works in
what's called the tangent space of the
manifold the tan
space is a flat space that you can
define at any point on the manifold so
here the manifold is the sphere at some
point P you define the tangent space as
simply the what the tangent a kind of a
imagine a sheet a straight sheet
touching the surface at point P so this
is now a flat space where we can define
a let's say a regular convolutional
kernel as we did laying it up here the
way that the question is how do you map
points from the sphere to this tangent
space and back and that's happening via
this exponential map the exponential map
in this sense is not the same as the
exponential map that you are used to
I simply exponentiating things the
exponential map here basically means if
I want to go from the from a point in
the tangent space to a point on the
manifold what I do is I take this vector
here which is a straight vector in the
tangent space and I go on the manifold
in this direction for a for a predefined
length so this is usually length of one
on the manifold for a predefined length
I walk into this direction along the
geodesic so long the shortest path in to
this direction and then I stop and where
I end up that's where I basically end up
so that's the corresponding point to
this point here on the tangent space so
to define a convolution fully it means
that first you lay your kernel and then
for each element in the kernel you will
multiply that kernel entry let me use a
blue here and multiply that kernel entry
by the corresponding point on the on the
manifold itself so by mapping this point
in the tangent space to the manifold or
you can also say you basically back
project from the manifold to the tangent
space and there
you do your regular convolution so
that's how you define a convolution in
the classic sense if you have for
example a sphere and what the authors
here of course noticed already is that
this is dependent on how you get there
and in technical terms it's called this
is dependent on your gauge so the gauge
basically is defining this coordinate
frame in the tangent space so this
tangent vector here is an abstract
object is just a vector but in order to
do something with it in order to do
something with a kernel and convolution
song you have to express it in numbers
and numbers are expressed with respect
to a base usually if you have a vector V
here you can express it with respect to
this two basis vectors so maybe V is
here is 2 and here is 3 so V can be
represented as the vector to 3 with
respect to the base e 1 e 2 and so this
choice of base basically is what's
called a gauge now I'm probably
butchering this topic completely for any
physicists or mathematicians listening
but just kind of give you an impression
yeah so this choice of basis is called a
a gauge and we can imagine a different
choice of basis so let me draw on other
bases here so another basis might be 1
right so e1 is here e 2 is here so the
new the new coordinates here would be
something like V can also be expressed
in this new basis as say 1 here's maybe
1 and this is very far so this may be 5
so 5 in this direction and to transform
between the two there is formulas
basically from from you know them from
linear algebra from vector spaces in
general they're called gate
transformations and if we want our
convolution to be invariant to be
basically the chosen coordinate frames
we have to say in technical terms what
we mean is the convolution should be
gauge equivariance that means no matter
which base we choose if we choose this
space or if we choose this the result
should basically be the same so within
the computation of the convolution we
must account for the fact of which gauge
is chosen and then basically have the
result be invariant and with the result
we don't mean the numbers of the result
because these will change but we mean
the the actual object that is resulting
the geometric object that is resulting
should be equivalent under gates to
gauge transformations so this is a a it
sounds very technical but the way I
understand it is basically you want to
define a convolution on these manifolds
such that you it's such that the result
is not dependent on exactly how you
shift the kernel around as long as you
account for the fact that you shifted it
around this way should give you the same
same result so for this day define a
condition and the condition is that the
kernel must behave as such so the V is
the input here and G minus one is a a
transformation of the of the gauge as I
understand it and so basically if you
transform the input by a different
coordinate frame then at the kernel
apply to that different input must
behave exactly as the kernel applied to
the original input
and then perturbed by these two
operations so this is this you might
notice this you might know things like
this from discussions maybe of what it
means for a function to be linear or
something where the function applied to
a transformed version must correspond to
the function applied to the original
version of the input transform to the
result transformed by some some
operation so if this holds so this is a
condition on the kernel of the
convolution and if you so if you define
your convolution in this way this is a
modification to the convolution on the
tangent space that we had then your
resulting your result will be gauge
equivalent what is this transformation
what is what is this new convolution
they define they say if you do the
convolution this way then these things
will hold so what is this this way
basically again you convolve the kernel
with the input but you the F here is the
input K is the kernel but what you do if
we come up here again what you do you
have to do a slight modification your
kernel here if you want to convert let's
say this point here you would not
combine this point with the point along
the exponential not corresponding to it
right this point here but what you would
do is you would transport this point
back along the geodesic to here and then
you would and then you would compute
your regular convolution so this means
sorry this is what this term here means
technically if you don't understand it
don't worry I don't either I guess
this is simply saying that if you
perform convolutions in on manifolds in
this way and you have the appropriate
kernel then they will be gay check we
variant so this is pretty cool because
what they do next is they define the
convolution on an icosahedron and an
icosahedron is a shape a 3d geometric
shape that's made of like triangles and
I can try to maybe they have drawn it
like Dever yes so all right this is an
icosahedron and so they can now define a
convolution on this with where a filter
is basically the filter looks like this
it's this kind of hexagons I yes and the
and the filter is kind of shifted around
and of course it's the problem is
whenever it shifts over one of these
boundaries here or whenever it shifts
over the these corners here what do you
do what do you do then because if you
look at it you can't basically flatten
the corner if you try to flatten the
corner you're gonna have this wedge
sticking out that's terrible you're
gonna have a a wedge here sticking out
if you try to flatten the corner so you
have to define basically the convolution
on this they do it in their framework
and specifically what they do is they
flatten and pad the icosahedron to this
representation so they put it into five
pieces they have to pad a bit you see
here each colored edge here this colored
edge corresponds to this colored edge so
that would be padded from here - nicely
define this convolution and then they
put this into a regular - the image with
the color things they are sometimes
repeated in this
image and then they define the filters
in this following way so this these are
the filters for basically for a 6
channel input image and what they have
to do is they have to do a weight
sharing between the filters in a very
specific way and in order for the kernel
to have these properties they need to
replicate these filters down here and if
you look the different colors in these
different let's call them channels they
each have different intensities and if
you look down here they're all slightly
different which means they're all
slightly different linear combinations
of the of the filter up here or
rotations basically they're all
differently arranged but they're
basically this blue field here is this
blue field but it's also let's see this
one and this one and this one and this
one so the the weights here are these
original filters are basically arranged
such that the weights are shared in this
form down here but if you do this if you
arrange them like this when you
replicate each filter basically six
times because you also want six output
channels then the filter will have the
desired properties and your convolution
will be gauge equi variant so they
applied is to - I call em nests so the
complete algorithm is actually down here
they can actually use if they pad the
image in the correct way to the 2d image
and expand the kernel to arrange it as
we just saw they can use a regular 2d
convolution to compute their result and
that's pretty cool and this means this
also is very very very efficient on this
icosahedron so what they do is they
apply this to echo em mist where they
project
basically they project em nest on an
icosahedron so they take the image em
nest and they project it onto this and
then they try to classify it on that I
can actually show that their method
outperforms other method and learns
these invariances so learns the
symmetries of the icosahedron or basic
sorry is invariant to them being
invariant to these symmetries means you
don't have to learn them anymore if
you're not invariant to symmetries it
means you have to learn each one of them
separately right but if your invariant
to symmetries then you have only have to
learn one thing once and then if the
icosahedron is rotated you're just like
mad it's just the same thing as this
other thing they also do this
interestingly to climate pattern
segmentation and also a kind of 2 or 3d
omnidirectional segmentation where
you're in a room a 3d room and you have
an omnidirectional picture sorry from
everywhere you have a picture a 3d
sphere picture from everywhere you're
asked to segment things in the room and
actually outperform all other methods on
these datasets so I find this extremely
cool that kind of this ultra theoretical
work starting out is ultra theoretical
then it gets implemented into something
that beats state-of-the-art methods on
irrelevant tasks all right so that was
just a brief overview and a very dirty
look at these things but I hope you got
something out of it and thus far I was
late for me but I